hallo mein name ist luca um meine lieben
freunde ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zum zweiten
teil von meinem flugsimulator
begeisterung hält sich in grenzen bei
mir allerdings nicht meine lieben
freunde denn ich werde mich heute zum
ersten mal in meinen lokführer setzen
eine blickfeld anzeige ist jetzt rechts
auf dem bildschirm diese zeigt an was
der zug macht ja die weiße nadel zeigt
ihre derzeitige geschwindigkeit die rote
markierung zeigt die derzeit erlaubte
höchstgeschwindigkeit
bisher gar nichts
drücken sie ihm zu beginnen dann drücke
ich mal dies ist das richtung center
display ein pfeil zeigt ihnen die
stellungen vorwärts rückwärts und
neutral
dieser zug ist bereit für die abfahrt
das schieben sie den angegebenen hebel
ganz nach vorn um loszufahren ist gut
dass er bereit ist denn jetzt geht's los
sieben zurück
wir fahren auch noch gar nicht mehr klar
ich bin der lokführer ich weiß dass ich
erst mal gas geben muss es einmal muss
ich natürlich in den durchsage machen
die strecke verläuft von hier aus bis
zur grenze zu den niederlanden und
belgien und ist teil des internationalen
strecken netzwerks von zügen die quer
durch europa fahren
das muss ich aber meinen fahrgästen
sagen
also
[Musik]
im zug handelt es sich um einen
intercity und verfügt über eine
höchstgeschwindigkeit von 320 kilometern
pro stunde ja aber wo
also wo ist der bus kommen uns nur eine
ansage hier im ece meiner lieben freund
[Musik]
meine damen und herren ich darf sie
recht herzlich willkommen hier heute auf
rund 13
fahrt von köln über niederlanden bis
nach belgien unser interesse brüssel
erreichen wir heute voraussichtlich
gegen 16 uhr 30 weiß sie wollten alle
schockiert vorankommen aber wir sind die
deutsche bahn verspätung ich werde diese
pubertät ordentlich anheizen und
losbrettern
ich hoffe sie haben sich alle gut
angeschnallt das geht nämlich bei uns
nicht volle fahrt voraus mit ihrem
lokführer luca lockt die einst im besitz
immer so richtig ein
[Musik]
das spiel ist wieder hängen geblieben
drei tage später
das ist
okay anscheinend müssen irgendwas mit
tasten machen ich kann
ist das
ist die geschwindigkeit
ich dachte es wird ein richtig geiles
video von wegen wir fahren jetzt hier
los und es geht ab und blabla aber
irgendwie bewegen uns ja nicht mal nicht
so richtig schlau raus ja
ich hab gerade die schöne irgendwie
gesperrt
das wird eingeleitet
ich habe die linken türen gesperrt und
die rechten fahren jetzt los
ich habe einen kollegen der arbeitet bei
der deutschen bahn
kölner hauptbahnhof bin ich
[Musik]
das ding hier das ist schritt für den
strom rechts daneben das hier ja dass
der hauptschalter
fünf stunden später
ich fahr los
ich war oft
ich verlost ich habe irgendwie sich um
den motor an gemacht ja ich melde mich
wenn ich muss jetzt nach brüssel
ja das war jetzt das war jetzt zwölf
minuten die ich jetzt gebraucht habe um
zu checken dass ich erst mal mit y den
motor einschaltet
aber meine damen und herren
in bewegung und verspätung von drei
tagen wir hoffen sie haben sich weitere
bordrestaurant gemütlich gemacht wurde
können sie heute unseres drinks genießen
rogers aus dem zweiten weltkrieg und
eine kumulative
wasser schmeckt
gefahren sind zwei monaten
wir sind jetzt in folge erstmals im
führerhäuschen wieder alleine ich kann
jetzt auf a drücken dann kann ich immer
ein bisschen erhöhen sowie leistungs
regler 37 wir schauen mal dahin sind
männer die im freundes und kollegen vor
mir
ich war aber nicht auf den zu sondern
wir fahren natürlich über unser anderes
gleis hier rechts anders
[Musik]
bitte bitte bitte
dann
ging's raus hier vorne rechts habe ich
einmal gewohnt einfach nur wenig züge so
liebe ich habe hier über geguckt zum
bahnhof dann allerdings ist jetzt mal
der mann marcus hook mir mit mikrofon
da war es gut wir um 1900 mit ihnen bei
der fahrt eine auswahl an verschiedenen
kameraansichten werfen wir jetzt einen
blick darauf während wir diesen zug
erkunden
guck mal die ringe meiner lieben freunde
hier ich wechseln indem sie den rechten
stick drücken
hier ist das saturn gebäude hier vorne
media park tower sehr sehr schön wir
haben dann hier vorne ist platz ist die
rechts um die ecke kann ja ein bisschen
zeigen hier die kathedrale von
nordspanien den mann kennen sie wir
können ein bisschen auf andere
perspektiven einmal anzuschauen zb von
hier
aber irgendwie sind ein bisschen
sie haben hier nur ein kleines gebiet
gesehen schauen wir was es sonst noch zu
entdecken gibt
wir kommen im westen von deutschland
bereiten sie sich auf eine
hochgeschwindigkeits vater auf der
ersten internationalen eisenbahnstrecke
der welt vor während sie den
vielseitigen gelenk trieb zu br 442
talent 2 fache internationale adress
oder beschaulicher inflation sie
bestimmen das tempo vergessen sie nicht
auf dem weg
meine damen und herren wir stürzen ein
anderes abenteuer und zwar immer noch in
köln allerdings mit schnee ihr seht
schon etwas weihnachten die rbs die
fahren hier rum meint ece wird
allerdings ein bisschen zugeschneit
deswegen würde ich sagen steigen wir ein
schließen hier die türken die wird
zugemacht glaube ich hoffe ich und wir
können uns dementsprechend hier rein
bewegen in unserem lokal
ganz kurz ihre einsetzen die türen jetzt
wieder mit y gesperrten linke seite und
nicht auf der rechten seite gesperrt
jetzt machen wir hier alles mal ein
bisschen besser uns war
[Musik]
nicht nur bremsung hier die gegenteil
haha kummer haben erstmal ein bisschen
licht hier am start so jetzt kann sie
nicht auch losgehen wir haben türen
steuerungen beide seiten öffnen beide
seiten schließen
guck mal jetzt geht's los beide seiten
werden geschlossen das heißt jetzt
gezwungen wir können auch losfahren sand
führend
wieso kann jeder fahren außer ich
mein leistungs regler den können wir
auch auf 100% donnern aufs maximum mir
passiert nicht sie zu bremsen ist gelöst
nix notbremsung los
was passiert hier nichts
[Musik]
ich will nichts öffne man ich will
einfach losfahren
[Musik]
störung
sei sie gespannt was
gesperrt
beeinflussung
scheiß drauf
wir scheißen einfach drauf das ist ein
absolutes spiel ich kriege es nicht mal
hin loszufahren ich habe kollegen
angerufen der fährt seit jahren
irgendwelche
güterzüge von würzburg nach köln und der
weiß ich wie man mit dem lot die not und
das ist ein verdammtes spiel was soll
denn diese scheiße alter das wollen sie
sich vielleicht auch kinder mal
anschauen und spielen stattdessen kriege
ich da selbst 25-jähriger mann nicht mal
hin das ist das hier störung
leistungsträger leistungsträgern
scheibenwischers einzigen sie aktivieren
konnten
gefallen sie widerspricht